yeah we're doing we're doing sexy Maps
today right so we're talking about sexy
primes well I'm not really qualified to
talk about sexiness I've come dressed as
a salsa teacher tonight so hooray but I
am qualified to talk about prime numbers
fortunately for me though in this case
sexy means another word for six so it's
six e primes that's what we're going to
do let's be honest the reason we're
doing this video is because it has a
funny name but let's see what a sexy
prime is okay so 60 prime or our two
primes actually that differ by six so if
I pick five that's a prime number and 11
those are two prime numbers and the
difference is six so they are called
sexy primes we can pick another example
let's pick seven and that's a Don six I
get 13 so a slightly bigger one then
let's pick 251 that is a prime number
and let's add on 6 and we'll get 257
let's pick some sexy triplets yeah yeah
he's a scaly more exciting all the time
isn't that 5 11 and 17 so those are
three prime numbers difference of 6
between them these are our sexy triplets
another one might be let's pick this I
picked that one on purpose so I could
use it again 251 257 let's add on 6
again and I get 263 all right sexy
quadruplets us pick 5 11 17 and add on 6
again 23 those are all prime numbers and
they are sexy sexy quintet clicky
absolutely right 5 11 17 23 29 these are
all prime numbers and that's a sexy
quintuplet that's not going to go to the
next level that one though is though it
isn't going to go to the next level
you're right if I add on 6 again I get
35 which is divided by 5
not a prime number and in fact that one
is the only sexy quintuplets that is the
only one that exists I can prove to you
that it's the only one exists can I
imagine you're going to pick a
quintuplets we'll call the first one
a-ok
and the next one ways you get a Don six
then April 6 so the next one is April 12
and the next one is a plus 18 and the
next one is a plus 24 like these are my
sexy quintuplet now these are all prime
numbers now if you had a remainder of
zero when you divide by five that means
it's a multiple of five do you remember
that from school when you divide by five
a remainder of zero means it's a
multiple of five if you had a remainder
of 5 or 10 or 15 that's another way of
saying it's a multiple of five if a has
a remainder of zero then it's a multiple
of five so five would work and we know
what this is then if this is five we get
eleven seventeen twenty three twenty
nine it is a different multiple of five
though if it's ten or fifteen it's not a
prime all right so we can get rid of
that what about when you divide by five
you get one left over by which I mean
what if it was 11 right you divide by
five and you have one left over a
remainder of one if that was true this
one over here would have a remainder of
25 and if it has a remainder of 25 it's
a multiple of five so it's not a prime
we can keep going if that has remainder
two that has remained a twenty and it's
a multiple of five it's not prime if
that has remainder three that has
remained a fifteen it's a multiple of
five it's not prime if that has remained
a four that has remained a ten it's a
multiple of five not prime it can only
work if the first number had a remainder
of zero and that only works if it's five
I've got something else about sixty
crimes so sixty crimes again it's a
funny name right so they have a
difference of six there's a similar idea
with other prime numbers though if they
differ by two
they're called twin primes if they
differ by for the called cousin primes
we have missed out threes though if they
they have a difference of three I don't
think they have a name we'll call them
triplet primes let's call them that and
but if you think about it if they're
different by three one of them has to be
even if they're different by three
now there's only one even prime number
it's two so the only triplet prime will
be two and five that's the only one but
we can keep going if they have a
difference of five what we're going to
call them
Quincy Prime's Quincy that reminds me of
Quincy solving crimes on a boat so if
they didn't difference of five same
reason though they have to have one of
them even so two and seven are going to
be Quincy primes if you keep going we've
talked about 60 Prime's so let's talk
about different subsets that's going to
be a septic prime which doesn't sound
very nice septic prime one of them has
to be even so to add on seven you get
nine which isn't prime there aren't any
septic Prime's we've shown there's no
septic Prime's if you keep going I think
the next one is the best one though
difference of eight to watch thing
that's going to call
Optimus Prime I think we can get a
difference of eight yeah let's try it a
sub 3 and 11 and 19 there you go we've
got an optimist PI prime triplet 3 2 and
11 will be a non nonny nonny non-letter
but surely it goes forever we're gonna
we've got a whole industry to make you
every I think I think how the views are
going to have fun making up their own
names now 7 times 8 divided by 2 that's
56 divided by 2 go wild 38 how many
second many hours do you want so the
next one let's say we did three to the
power of 2 the power
Oh arrow arrow arrow why - you call this
and that will give you the third perfect
number